You were quite into video
games when you were growing up.
Yes.
Were you a gamer?
I wouldn't call myself a gamer.
I was exclusively obsessed
with the game Zelda
(audience cheers)
for super Nintendo,
Right.
the greatest game ever made.
What made that game so great?
It was pure magic.
Right.
Foolish me.
You know there're just.
I was obsessed with boots, boob slap,
you know, was just like,
I just
It was also a little known Nintendo game.
I was never really into the, you know, the
I guess the, the fighting game.
I liked the story games.
It was a great story.
You know.
You get nostalgic for those old.
I do.
Do you play any new games now?
Do you ever?
I don't so much now.
I actually have a couple of game systems,
but I don't, I don't really play now.
When I was 12 though,
I had the Super Nintendo
I got for Christmas
and I got so obsessed with
Zelda that I realized how
that I was addicted to playing it.
And I gave my system away,
because I realized I couldn't, you know,
that I was spending
hours on hours playing.
And.
So you went cold turkey.
That was very responsible of you.
Yeah.
Most kids don't do that.
Well yeah.
(Zooey laughs)
That's what I hear.
I have seven year old
and we like really limit
his access to screen time,
but he's obsessed with Clash of Clans,
Oh, I don't know.
which is this thing where people,
you can set up a little village,
and then other people come attack it.
Oh.
And to be a good dad, I was like
I'm going to do it with you.
So I set up a little village.
Every morning, I check my clan
and they've kicked the crap
out of me in the night.
(audience laughs)
So every day begins with me in, you know,
I've had my ass kicked.
My village has been destroyed.
I'm upset.
That's terrible.
My son's laughing.
The whole thing with playing is,
I realized my mom would
say I had like an hour
or something to play.
And then when she come
to pull me, I'd be like,
"No!
I'm about to get to the dark world."
You know,
Yeah.
And it's really upsetting.
It turns.
I really was invested.
It turns children
into Gollum and they're like,
"I must have my precious."
You know.
Yeah, exactly.
My precious.
That was good.
Thank you.
I love that.
Do that and Elvis, no, I'm kidding.
You have this great website.
Hello Giggles.
Hello Giggles and it features
just things that are upbeat
and positive
Oh yeah.
You need to checkout.
Sure.
And I was looking at it the other day,
and I got kind of lost in.
You have, I mean, you
have puppies and kittens
and fun things
Yeah.
and there's one, that's just sea horses.
Sea Horse Cam.
Let's show that.
It's just really nice.
(chimes and slow guitar music plays)
(Zooey laughs)
(slow music continues)
[Conan] It's very peaceful.
and then I realized,
(audience laughs)
then I realized
that the music is just
what's calming me down.
(Zooey laughs)
So I changed the music
and it's a completely
different experience.
(spooky organ music plays)
(audience laughs)
(audience claps)
It's all strangling.
It's strangling.
I know you made,
I've never seen seahorses seems so evil.
Yeah.
So my, you know
and there's why do they
strangle each other?
Did you know that that
was part of your website?
Is they're all strangling each other.
I don't know.
I'll work on it.
(Conan laughs)